like being with her
that's Blake Shelton gushing over his
girlfriend Gwen Stefani backstage at
Monday's taping of The Voice his new
album if I'm honest is full of heartfelt
tracks like a guy with a girl which is
of course about a guy who can't believe
he's with such a gorgeous girl do you
like being with when when she's all
dolled up like that or do you like it a
little better Oh natural I just like
being with her but when she's all dolled
up and we go places it's always fun for
me she was here right now not one person
here it would be looking at anybody else
but her you know they may come up and
talk to me but it's only because I'm one
person over from her you know pretty
cool one night girl is another one that
I love reminds me a lot of seeing all of
Gwen's snapchats of her and her boys
being in Oklahoma with you how are they
taking the country life are you teaching
them to hunt and fish I don't see them
much because if they're at my place in
Oklahoma they're in the woods
I don't know how to keep control of them
you know the whole kid thing for me is
like oh my gosh well you know what
that's what I grew up doing come back
for dinner you know come back for dinner
and when it comes to the couple's duet
go ahead and break my heart Blake said
he's down to perform it together on the
road if she ever hit one of my shows or
I met one of her shows I know wolf
we got to do it you know but this is the
guy that I wanted I'll just do the I'll
just do Glen's part yeah I love that
like this gal sure that's it I want to
tell you